you seem like a bandage stealing time
hundred Cowboys Deerhunter go away
they're mine just stop being so
basic oh I got a gram the out of
this
the little Colleen coalition the only
sassy sexy sophomores in honors history
rock in the smocks where's the
pepto-bismol
you what over there sorry aboot that
he's such a sitcom yeah well we closed
in 20 minutes so if he pukes you're
cleaning it up let me ask you something
you ladies like working the Zed not at
all customers make it suck yeah you know
what wouldn't suck Colleen and Colleen
with me in between the very definition
of suck are the Colleen's perchance
working tomorrow not on Friday night no
way we're off why I would like to invite
you both to my party a senior party I
knew you're learning now with two very
cool sophomores may I have the honor of
your number Mademoiselle